the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so remember we've seen Stokes
theorem which says if I have a closed
curve in space bounding some surface s
and I orient the curve and the surface
compatibly with each other then I can
compute a line integral along c along my
curve in terms of instead a surface
integral for flux of a different vector
field
let me call f dot NDS okay so that's the
statement and just to clarify a little
bit so again you know we've seen various
kinds of integrals so line integrals we
know how to evaluate
vertic placing a curve you express
everything in terms of one variable and
after substituting you end up with a
usual one variable integral that you
know how to evaluate and surface
integrals we know also how to evaluate
namely we've seen various formulas for
NDS once you have such a formula you do
the dot product with this vector field
which is not the same as that one but
it's a new vector field that you can
build out of f you do the dot product
you express everything in terms of your
two integration variables and then you
evaluate so now what does this have to
do with various other things so one
thing I want to say has to do with how
Stokes
helps us understand path independence so
how it actually motivates our criterion
for gradient field independence
okay so we've seen we've said that if we
have a vector field defined in a simply
connected region and its curl is zero
then it's a gradient field and the line
integral is path independent so let me
first define for you what a simply
connected region is so we say that the
region in space is simply connected if
every closed loop inside this region
bounds some surface again inside this
region ok so let me just give you some
examples just to clarify so
for example let's say that they have a
region that's the entire space with the
origin removed
okay so space with the origin removed
okay do you think it's simply connected
to things it's simply connected who
thinks it's not simply connected let's
think a little bit harder let's say that
I take a loop like this one okay it
doesn't go for the origin can I find a
surface that's bounded by this loop and
that does not pass for the origin yeah I
can take the sphere you know for example
or any anything that's just not quite
the disk so and you know similarly if I
take any other loop that avoids the
origin I can find actually a surface
bounded by it that does not pass for the
origin so actually that's a kind of a
not so obvious theorem to prove but
maybe intuitively start by finding any
surface well if its surface passes for
the origin just wiggle it a little bit
you can make sure it doesn't pass for
the origin anymore you just push it a
little bit so in fact this is simply
connected that was a trick question
okay now on the other hand a good
example of something that is not simply
connected is if I take space and I
remove the z-axis
that is not simply connected and see the
reason is if I look again say at the
unit circle in the x-axis so in unit
circle in the XY plane in the XY plane
so if I try to find the surface whose
boundary is this disc well it has to
actually cross the z axis somewhere
there's no way that I can find a surface
whose only boundary is this curve which
doesn't hit the z axis anywhere of
course you could try to you know use the
same trackers there say you know maybe
we want to go up up up you know let's
start with a cylinder well the problem
is you would have to go infinitely far
because the z axis goes infinitely far
and you'll never be able to actually
close your surface so no matter what
kind of trick you might want to use it's
actually a theorem in topology that you
cannot find a surface bounded by this
disc without intersecting the z axis yes
well a doughnut shape certainly would
stay away from the z axis but it
wouldn't be a surface with bound away
just this guy right it would have to
have either some other boundary you know
if your surface so maybe what you have
in mind is some sort of doughnut shape
like this that curves on itself and
maybe comes back well if you don't quite
close it all the way around so I can try
to indeed the hole some sort of donut
here
well if I don't quite close it when it
will have another edge at the other end
where I started if I close it completely
when this curve is no longer its
boundary because my surface lives on
both sides of this curve see I want a
surface that stops on this curve and
doesn't go beyond it and nowhere else
does it have a kind of behavior
everywhere else it keeps going on so
so actually I mean you know baby
actually the another way to convince
yourself is to find a counterexample to
the statement I'm going to make about
vector fields with curl 0 in simply
connected regions always being
conservative so what you can do is you
can take the example that we had in one
of our older problem sets that was a
vector fill in the plane but just you
know you can also use it to define the
vector field in space just with no Z
component that vector field is actually
defined everywhere except on the z axis
and it violates the usual theorem that
we would expect so that's one way to
check you know just for sure that this
thing is not simply connected
so what's the statement I want to make
so recall we've seen if F is a gradient
field then it's curl is zero that's just
the fact that the mixed second partial
derivatives are equal so now the
converse is the following theorem it
says if the curl of F equals zero in
soil and F is defined no it's not
biological way in which to say it so if
F is defined in a simply connected
region and curl F is zero then F is a
gradient field and the line integral for
F is path independent F is conservative
and so on all the usual consequences
remember these are all equivalent to
each other for example because you can
use path independence to define the
potential by doing the line integral of
F ok so where do we use the assumption
of being defined in a simply connected
region well the way in which we will
prove this is to use Stokes theorem so
the proof so I'm just going to prove
that the line integral is path
independent we of us walk the same way
okay so let's assume that we have a
vector field whose curl is zero and
let's say that we have two curves c1 and
c2 that go from some point p0 to some
point p1 the same point to the same
point well we'd like to understand the
line integral along c1 say minus the
line integral along c2 to show that this
is zero that's what we are trying to
prove so how will we compute that well
the line integral along c1 minus c2 well
let's just from a closed curve that is
c1 minus c2
okay so let's call C oops
so that's equal to the integral along c
of F dot d R where C is C 1 followed by
C 2 backwards now C is a closed curve so
I can use Stokes theorem well to be able
to use Stokes theorem I need actually to
find the surface to apply it to and
that's where the assumption of simply
connected is useful I know in advance
that any closed curve C in particular
has to bounce some surface okay so we
can find s a surface s that bounds C
because the region is simply connected
so now that tells us we can actually
apply Stokes theorem so it won't fit
here so instead I will do that on the
next line that's equal by Stokes to the
double integral of our s of curl F dot
vector D s on NDS but now the curl is
zero so if I integrate 0 I will get 0
okay so I've proved that my two line
integrals along c1 and c2 were equal but
for that I needed to be able to find a
surface to which apply which to apply
Stokes theorem and that required my
region to be simply connected if I had a
vector field that was defined on the
outside of the z axis and I took two
paths that went on one side and the
other side of the z axis
I might have obtained actually different
values of the line integral okay so
anyway that's the customary warning
about
simply connected things okay let me just
mention very quickly that there's a lot
of interesting topology you can do
actually in space so for example this
concept of being simply connected or not
and studying which loops bound surfaces
or not can be used to classify shapes of
things inside space so for example one
of the founding achievements of topology
in the 19th century was to classify
surfaces in space by trying to look at
loops on them so what I mean by that is
if I take the surface of a sphere
well I claim the surface of a sphere is
simply connected why is that well let's
take my favorite closed curve on the
surface of the sphere I can always find
a portion of the sphere that's bounded
by it so that's the definition of the
surface of a sphere being simply
connected on the other hand if I take
what's called a torus or if you prefer
the surface of a doughnut if that's more
it's a less technical term but it's
then that's not simply connected and in
fact you know for example if you look at
this loop here that goes around it well
of course it bounds a surface in space
but that surface cannot be made to be
just a piece of the donut you have to go
through the hole you have to leave the
surface of the torus in fact there's
another one see this one also does not
bounce anything that's completely
contained invertors and of course it
bounds this disc that's inside of a
torus but that's not a part of the
surface itself so in fact verse
topologies would say that's true
independent loops that don't bounce off
phases that don't bound anything and so
this number two is somehow an invariant
that you can associate to this kind of
shape and then if you consider more
complicated surfaces with more holes in
them you can try somehow to count
independent loops on them and that's the
beginning of the classification of
surfaces anyway that's not really an it
not to topic but I thought I would
mention it because
it's kind of a cool idea okay let me say
a bit more in the way of you know fun
remarks like that
so food for thought let's say that I
want to apply Stokes theorem to simplify
a line integral along this curve here
okay so this curve is maybe not easy to
see on the picture it kind of goes twice
around the z axis but spirals up and
then down okay so one way to find a
surface that's bounded by this curve is
to take what's called the Mobius strip
okay so the Mobius strip it's a
one-sided strip where when you go around
you flip one side becomes the other so
you know you just if you want to take a
band of paper and glue the two sides
with a with a twist so that's a
one-sided surface and that gives us
actually serious trouble if we try to
orient it to apply Stokes theorem so see
for example if I take this Mobius strip
and they try to find an orientation
since we head looks like that well let's
say that I've oriented my curve going in
this direction so I go around around
around still go in this direction
well the orientation I should have for
Stokes theorem is that when I so have
continues here in case well if you look
at the convention around here it tells
us that the normal vector should be
going this way if we look at it near
here if we walk along this way the
surfaces - all right so we should
actually be flipping things upside down
the normal vector should be going down
and in fact you know if you try to
follow your normal vector that's
pointing up it's pointing up up it will
have to go bit into things into into
down there's no way to choose
consistently a normal vector for from
you strip so that's what that's what we
call a non iron table surface and that
just means you know it has only one side
and if it has only one side then we
cannot speak of flux for it because we
have no way of saying that we'll be
counting things positively one way
negatively the other way because there's
only one you know there's no notion of
sides so you can't define the side
towards which things will be going
positively so that's actually a
situation where flux cannot be defined
okay so as much as Mobius strips and
Klein bottles exciting and really cool
well we can't use them in this class
because we can't define flux for them so
if we really want it to apply Stokes
theorem because I've been telling you
for vaginal space is simply connected
and I will always be able to apply
Stokes theorem to any curve what would I
do
well I claim this curve actually bounds
another surface that is are in table
yeah that looks counterintuitive well
let's see it I claim you can take a
hemisphere and you can take a small
thing and twist it around so in case you
don't believe me let me do it again with
the transparency here's my loop and see
well the scale is not exactly the same
so it doesn't quite match but and it's
getting a bit dark but that spherical
thing with a little slit going twisting
into it will actually have boundary my
loop and that one is on table I mean I
let it I leave it up to you to stare at
the picture long enough to convince
yourselves that there's a well-defined
up-and-down
okay
so now I mean in case you're getting
really really worried I mean you know
there won't be any mobius strips on the
examine Tuesday okay it's just to you
know show you some cool stuff okay
questions nope okay one last thing I
want to show you before we start
reviewing so one question you might have
about Stokes theorem is how come we can
choose whatever surface we want I mean
sure it seems to work but why so I'm
going to say a couple of words about
surface independence in Stokes theorem
so let's say that I have a curve C in
space and let's say that I want to apply
Stokes theorem so then I can choose my
favorite surface bounded by C so in
situation like this for example I might
want to make my first choice B this guy
s1 know like maybe some sort of upper
half sphere and if you pay attention to
the orientation conventions you'll see
that you need to take it with normal
vector pointing up maybe actually I
would rather make a different choice and
actually I will choose another surface
s2 that maybe looks like that and if I
look carefully at the orientation
Convention Stokes theorem tells me that
I have to take the normal vector
pointing up again so that's actually in
two things so Stokes says that the line
integral along c of my favorite vector
field can be computed either as a flux
interval as a flux integral for the curl
through s1r as the same integral but for
s2 instead of s1 so that seems to
suggest that you know curl F has some
sort of surface independence property it
doesn't
matter which surface I take as long as
the boundary is with given curve see why
is that
let's just range property to have where
does it come from well let's think about
it for a second so why are we is the
same I mean of course we have to be the
same so that in because that's what
Stokes tells us but why is that okay
well let's think about comparing the
flux integral for s1 and the flux
integral for s2 so if we want to compare
them we should probably subtract them
from each other okay so let's do the
flux integral for s1 minus the flux
integral for s2 of the same thing well
let's give a name let's call s the
surface s1 minus s2 so what is s s is s1
with its given orientation together with
s2 with the reversed orientation so s is
actually this whole closed surface here
and the normal vector to s seems to be
pointing outwards everywhere okay so now
if we have a closed surface with the
normal vector pointing outwards and we
want to find a flux integral fluid well
we can replace that with a triple
integral so that's the divergence
theorem
so that's by the divergence theorem
using the fact that s is a closed
surface that's equal to the triple
integral over the region inside let me
call that region D of divergence of curl
F G D okay and what I'm going to claim
now is that we can actually check that
if you take the divergence of the curl
of a vector field
you always get zero okay and so that
will tell you that this integral will
always be zero and that's why the flux
for s 1 and flux for s 2 were the same a
priori and we don't have to worry about
which one we chose when we did Stokes
theorem okay so let's just check quickly
that divergence of a curl is zero in
case you're wondering why I'm doing all
this well first I think it's kind of
interesting and second you know it
reminds you of the statement of all
these theorems and all these definitions
so in a way we're already reviewing ok
so let's see if my vector field has
components P Q and R remember that the
curl was defined by this cross product
between Dell and our given vector field
so that's why minus QZ
followed by P Z minus R X and Q X minus
P Y so now we want to take the
divergence of this well so we have to
take the first component ry minus Q Z
and take its partial with respect to X
then take the Y component P Z minus R X
path respect to y plus QX minus py
partial respect to Z and well now we
should expand this but I claim it will
always simplify to zero
[Applause]
ok so I think we have above air becomes
a sub y X minus Q sub Z X plus P sub Z Y
minus R sub X y plus Q sub X Z minus P
sub y Z well let's see we have P sub Z Y
minus P sub y Z these two cancel out we
have R sub YX minus R sub X Y this
cancel out Q sub Z X and Q sub X Z these
two also cancel out so indeed the
divergence of a curl is always 0 ok so
the claim is divergence of curl is
always 0 del dot del cross F is always 0
and just a small remark if we had
actually real vectors you know having
this strange del guy indeed we know that
if we have two vectors U and V and we do
u dot u cross V what is that well one
way to say it is it's the determinant of
U U and V which is the volume of a box
but it's completely flat because u U and
V are all in the plane defined by U and
V we have a way to say it is that u cos
B is perpendicular to u and V well it's
perpendicular to u when its dot product
with u will be 0 so no matter how you
say it
this is always 0 so in a way this
reinforces our intuition that Dell even
though it's not at all an actual vector
sometimes it can be manipulated in the
same way
okay I think that's it for new topics
for today and so now I should maybe try
to recap quickly what we've learned in
this past three weeks so that you know
so the exam is probably going to be
similar in difficulty to the practice
exams that's my goal I don't know if I
will have reached that goal or not we'll
only know that after you've taken the
test but the idea is it's meant to be
more or less the same level of
difficulty so at this point we've
learned about three kinds of beasts in
space okay so I'm going to divide my
blackboard into three pieces and here I
will write triple integrals we've learnt
about double integrals and we've learnt
about line integrals okay so triple
integrals over a region in space we
integrate a scalar quantity DV how do we
do that well we can do that in
rectangular coordinates where DV becomes
maybe something like DZ DX dy or any
permutation of these we've seen how to
do it also in cylindrical coordinates
where VV is maybe DZ times Rd Rd theta
or more commonly rdrd theta DZ but what
I want to emphasize in this way is that
both of these you set up pretty much in
the same way so remember the main trick
here is to find the bounds of
integration so when you do it say with
DZ first that means for fixed XY so for
a fixed point in the XY plane you have
to look at the bounds for Z so that
means you have to figure out
what's the bottom surface of your solid
and what's the top surface of your solid
and you have to find the value of Z at
the bottom the value of Z at the top as
functions of x and y and then you will
put that as bounds for Z and once you've
done that you're left with a question of
finding bounds for x and y well for that
you just rotate the picture look at your
solid from above so look at its
projection to the XY plane and you set
up a double integral either in
rectangular XY coordinates or in polar
coordinates for X and Y of course you
can also do it in different orders and
I'll let you figure out again how that
goes but if you do dizzy first then the
inner bounds are given by bottom and top
and the outer ones are given by looking
at the shadow of your region
now there's also spherical coordinates
and then we've seen that DV is Rho
squared sine Phi D Rho D Phi D theta so
now of course if this Adri of greek
letters is confusing you at this point
then you probably need to first review
spherical coordinates for themselves
remember that hole is the distance from
the origin fee is the angle down from
the z-axis so it's zero on the positive
z axis PI over 2 in the XY plane and
increases all the way to PI on the
negative z axis and theta is the angle
around the z axis so now when we set up
bounds here it will look a lot like what
you've done in polar coordinates in the
plane because when you look at the inner
bound down on a hole for a fixed fee and
theta that means you're shooting a
straight away from the origin in some
direction in space so you know you're
sending a laser beam and you want to
know what part of your beam is going to
be in your given solid you want to solve
for the value of ho when you enter the
solid and when you leave it I mean very
often if the origin is in your solid
then all will start at 0 then you want
to know when you exit and I mean there's
a fairly small list of kinds of surfaces
that we've seen how to set up in sphere
coordinate so you know if you're really
obsessed by this go over the problems in
the notes that will give you a good idea
of what kinds of things we've seen in
cycle coordinates okay and then
evaluation is the usual way questions
about this okay
so I should say we can do something bad
but so we've seen of course applications
of this so we should know how to use a
triple integral to evaluate things like
a mass of a solid the average value of a
function the moment of inertia about one
of the coordinate axes or the
gravitational attraction on a mass at
the ID
okay so these are just formulas to
remember for examples of triple
integrals doesn't change conceptually
you always set them up and evaluate them
the same way it just tells you what to
put there for the integrand now double
integrals so when we have a surface in
space well what we will integrate on it
just what we've seen how to integrate is
a vector field dotted with the unit
normal vector times the area element
okay and this is sometimes called vector
DS now how do we evaluate that well
we've seen formulas for NDS in various
settings
and once you have a formula for NDS that
will relate NDS - maybe dxdy or
something else and then you will Express
so for example NDS equals something DX
dy and then it becomes a double integral
of something DX dy now in the integrand
you want to express everything in terms
of x and y so if you had a Z maybe you
have a formula for Z in terms of X and Y
and when you set up the bounds where you
try to figure out whatever bounds for X
and y that would be just looking at it
from above because if you're using other
variables figure out the bounds for
those variables then when you've done
that it becomes just a double integral
in the usual sense okay so maybe I
should be a bit more explicit about
formulas because there have been a lot
so let me tell you about a few of them
let me actually do that over here
because
I don't want to make this too crowded
okay so what kinds of formulas for NDS
have we've seen well we've seen a
formula for example for a horizontal
plane for something that's parallel to
the Y Z plane or the XZ plane well let's
do just the Y Z plane for a quick
reminder so if I have a surface that's
contained inside the Y Z plane then
obviously I will express D's in terms of
when I will use y&z as my variables so I
will say that D s is dy DZ or DZ dy
whatever's most convenient maybe we'll
even switch to polar coordinates after
that if a problem wants us to and what
about the normal vector well the normal
vector is either coming straight at us
oh it's maybe going back away from us
depending on which one even we've chosen
so this gives us NDS we dot our favorite
vector field with it we integrate and we
get the answer we've seen about spheres
and cylinders centered at the origin or
centered on the z axis so the normal
vector sticks straight out or straight
in depending on which direction you do
it in so force feel the normal vector is
X Y Z divided by the radius of the
sphere for a cylinder its XY 0 divided
by the radius of the cylinder and the
surface element on a sphere so see it's
very closely related to the volume
element of spherical coordinates except
you don't have a hole anymore
you just plug in or equals a
so you get a squared sine Phi D Phi D
theta and for a cylinder it would be a
DZ D theta so by the way I mean just a
quick sanity check you know when you're
doing an integral if it's a surface
integral there should be two integral
signs and there should be two
integration variables and there should
be two D some things if you have a wrong
number of you know if you end up with a
DX dy DZ in the surface integral
something is seriously wrong okay now
besides these specific formulas we've
seen two general formulas that are also
useful so one is if we know how to
express Z in terms of X and Y and just
to change notation to show you that it's
not you know set in stone let's say that
Z is known as a function Z of x and y so
how do I get NDS in that case well we've
seen a formula that says negative
partial Z partial X negative partial Z
partial y one dxdy so this formula
relates the volume beside the surface
element on our surface to the area
element in the XY plane
it lets us convert between DS and DX dy
okay so we just plug in this and we dot
with F and then we substitute everything
in terms of X and Y and we evaluate the
integral over x and y if we don't really
want to find a way to find Z as a
function of x and y but we have a normal
vector given to us
then we have another formula which says
that NDS is sorry I should have said
it's always up to sign because we have a
two or in different conventions we have
to decide based on what we are trying to
do whether we are doing the correct
convention or the wrong one so if the
other formula is n of our n dot k DX dy
so are they all the same there's no oh
well if you want you can put an absolute
value here but it doesn't matter because
it's up to sign anyway so I mean this
formula is valid as it is okay and they
will all eventually even if you try you
know if you're in a situation where you
can apply more than one formula they
will all give you the same answer in the
end because it's the same flux integral
okay so anyway so we have various ways
of computing surface integrals and
probably one of the best possible things
you can do to prepare for the test is
actually to look again at some practice
problems on the nodes that do flux
integrals over various kinds of surfaces
because that's probably one of the
hardest topics in this unit of the class
okay anyway let's move on to line
integrals so now those are actually a
piece of cake in comparison okay because
all that this is is just integral of pdx
plus qdy plus rdz and then all you have
to do is parameterize the curve C to
Express
everything in terms of a single variable
and then you end up with a usual single
integral and you can just compute it so
that one works pretty much as it did in
the plane so if you haven't forgotten
what within the plane it's really the
same thing
okay so now we have three different
kinds of integrals and really you know
well they certainly have in common that
we integrate things somehow but apart
from that they are extremely different
in what they do I mean this one involves
a function a scalar quantity these
involve vector quantities they don't
involve the same kinds of shapes over
which to integrate here you integrate
over a three-dimensional region here you
integrate only over a two-dimensional
surface and here on a one-dimensional
curve so try not to confuse them that's
basically the most important advice you
know don't get mistaken each of them has
a different way of getting evaluated
eventually they will all give you
numbers but for different processes so
now well I said these guys are
completely different
well they are but we still have some
wedges between them ok so we have two
maybe I'll say three well two bridges
between these guys okay so we have
somehow a connection between vs which is
the divergence theorem we have a
connection between that which is Stokes
theorem so
just to fight them again so the
divergence theorem says if I have a
region in space and I call its boundary
s so it's going to be a closed surface
and I orient s with a normal vector
pointing outwards then whenever I have a
surface integral over F over s sorry I
can replace it by a triple integral over
the region inside okay so this guy is a
vector field and this guy is a function
that somehow relates to the vector field
you could even know how you should know
the definition of the divergence of
course but what I want to point out is
if you have to compute the two sides
separately well this is just you know
your standard flux integral this is just
your standard triple integral over a
region in space once you have computed
what this guy is it's really just the
triple integral of a function so the way
in which you compute it doesn't see that
it came from the divergence it's just
the same way that you would compute any
other triple integral the way we compute
it doesn't depend on what it what
actually we are integrating Stokes
theorem says if I have a curve that's
the boundary of the surface s and I
orient the two incompatible manners then
I can replace a line integral on C by a
surface integral on s ok and that
surface integral well it's not for the
same vector field this relates a line
integral from one field to a surface
integral from another field that other
field is given on the first one just by
taking its curl so after you take the
curl you obtain a different vector field
and the way in which you will compute
the surface integral is just as with any
surface integral you just find a formula
for NDS dot product substitute evaluate
the calculation of this thing once
you've computed curl does not remember
that it was a curl it's the same as with
any other flux integral okay and finally
the last bridge so this was like between
2 & 3 this was between 1 & 2 let me just
save as a bridge between 0 & 1 which is
that if you have a function and it's
gradient
well the fundamental theorem of calculus
says that the line integral for the
vector field given by the gradient of a
function is actually equal to the change
in value of a function that if you have
a curve bounded by p0 and p1 so in a way
actually
each of these three films relate a
quantity with a certain number of
integral signs to a quantity with one
more integral sign and that's actually
somehow a fundamental similarity between
them but maybe it's easier to think of
them as completely different stories so
now with this one we additionally have
to remember another topic is given a
vector field F with curl equal to zero
find the potential and we've seen two
methods for that and I'm sure you
remember them so if not then try to
remember them for Tuesday ok so anyway
again conceptually we have really three
different kinds of integrals we evaluate
them in completely different ways and
first we have a handful of theorems
connecting them to each other but that
doesn't have any impact on how we
actually compute things